hey guys bit of a different video today
welcome to code tech tutorials my name
is matt in this video i want to talk
about getting out of tutorial hell
you've all heard of that right and
naturally as i'm a channel that
literally makes tutorials i should know
how to get out of tutorial hell right
well
it's uh quite simple really when you
think about it when you go to program or
do something like say you're using a new
language or you're just getting into
programming so you want to do something
you look up some basic tutorials you
look up some projects they kind of walk
you through it but examples get outdated
and things break and you get stuck
halfway through and you just kind of go
through this thing where you're just
continuously doing tutorials
and uh how do you get past that right
how do you get to a level where you
actually do what you want you don't even
have to look at any tutorials you just
start doing the thing well there is a
place for tutorials and it is usually
the introduction
when you want to get past and out of
tutorials you have to start looking at
specifications you have to look at the
manual for how to use things and maybe
you go to some website you get
walkthroughs or you watch videos and you
get walkthroughs that's all fine for
some basic starting points but for any
of these things that they're using any
of the tools that they're using in those
videos they all have manuals and
documentation and you need to look
through that stuff say you want to do a
little more
tutorials don't seem to have what you're
thinking of maybe you might want to
start looking at the reference pages
there and of course they're not going to
make sense at first so you're probably
going to have to go find some kind of
examples or tutorials a little bit and
that's what the tutorials are for just
to kind of get your feet wet they're not
really for replacing documentation and
you know i usually go to tutorials the
first time i learn anything because well
you kind of want to get the
initialization like how do you get it
initialized right and then once you have
the thing initialized sure you can keep
following but you could also just start
going on your own and it's like that for
everything there's documentations that
are not tutorials that just tell you
what functions and things do and
you can go off of those and use your own
creativity and that is kind of where
things like design patterns come in
handy but you don't even really need to
know those you just need to be good at
problem solving because most of those
come somewhat naturally when you think
about it and if you haven't necessarily
thought about it then reviewing all that
stuff helps and of course there's
algorithms but algorithms is more
concerned with optimizing and speeding
up code in general when you talk about
it so a lot of times if you're doing
something custom there isn't an obvious
algorithm or an obvious workflow
sometimes you gotta make it up sometimes
you're coming up with a new product at
this point in software development there
aren't a whole lot of new products
almost everything is generally about the
same there's a lot of replication these
days all the big apps they're all
basically the same thing you know they
all do media support and you can like
and post and make accounts and like
every social media app is a replication
of that with maybe a different tiny bit
of different
logic somewhere but in general it's all
the same stuff so that's the reason
tutorials are so good too because like
what are you gonna do besides that i
don't know it's up to you but you can
get that base that everyone's already at
often through tutorials a lot of times
you have to dig into some documentation
because once you get like deep into it
you know programming takes a lot of time
people will spend months and months
working on their thing and when they're
finally done with it the last thing they
want to do is go back through and make
tutorials for everything or if they're
making tutorials in the middle of doing
their thing i run into this a lot
when i'm implementing something
sometimes they'll think okay this is
great i got this all figured out i
should make a tutorial on it and what
happens is rather than moving on from my
problem that i already solved i say i
stay stuck in it for another day or two
kind of like developing a tutorial
around it or something but uh maybe
better just to one-shot those and do
them real quick because they do take a
lot of time to uh edit and stuff but
what happens there is it slows down your
project progress because you're now
stopping and shifting focus in to making
tutorials so what i'm getting to hear is
people that often actually complete
these apps and and have all the
knowledge they don't share it because it
takes so much dang time to put it out
there it's easier for them to just keep
going with their job or work and stay
focused on that and not worry about you
know
the whole side of training people all
the time which is basically what making
tutorials and stuff feels like that's
what this channel is for basically just
you know helping out people that are
either stuck or want to know more or
just getting into it so to summarize
basically you want to use the tutorial
as a hello world and a starting off
point and you want to use it to maybe
gain some understanding but it's not
necessarily going to be for your project
because once you dig into the
documentation and start reading stuff
that's when you realize there's little
things here and there that you can make
a lot better that's often how it goes so
yeah just tutorials only a starting off
point if you really want to do the thing
you got to be digging into the manuals
and trying to kind of push the
boundaries of what that thing is i'm
being vague purposely because this
really applies to all areas just depends
what direction you're going you've
really got to take in what you can in
that day
another thing i see happen a lot is
people just overwhelm themselves with
the stuff they feel like they need to
know and then it's too much so they just
never do it and the way to approach that
i think is to just take a small bite you
gotta you gotta have a small idea you
wanna do something big you got to pick a
small piece of that just pick an area
and kind of learn a little bit of that
and it's really that for everything even
the web stack you know you got to learn
a piece at a time and you're not going
to do it all in one day you might be
able to get a broad overview in a day
and uh maybe if you go through a quick
tutorial of setting up the different
pieces you might be able to get most of
it in a day or two if you're super good
but that's assuming everything's clean
and there's no errors which tends to
happen you usually run into stuff and
that's when you gotta really dig in can
you kind of come naturally out of the
tutorial phase at some point but you
also always go back to it at some point
especially when you're learning
something new and just need a starting
off point and need someone to kind of
explain some things to you that's uh
that's really what it's for if you
already have a teacher you might already
know all this stuff so you might go
right to the documentation you know a
lot of it is just time to
and uh coming back day after day that's
what builds up a lot of getting out of
that face and uh now you know the last
thing i'll mention is just actually
working on a project um
it almost you know i've said this before
but it really doesn't matter a whole lot
what it is you just need something that
you're passionate about and something
that you kind of have a goal with and
that's and that's it you can keep
working on that if you don't have a goal
with it anymore you can always shift
projects you know
if you don't have the drive to make your
own projects or jump on projects there's
tons of people that need help and even
if you tell them you're just learning
they'll probably still accept your help
because there's a lot of work to be done
in a code base and some of the stuff is
like i don't know even kind of obvious
for newbies once they start digging in
it's just uh i think every coder helps
definitely all right well let me know
what you got your guys's thoughts are
down below i'll see in the next one
peace